Professor Amy
Hungerford: Today is Novel
Pitch Day.
Does everyone have a ballot?
If you don't have a ballot,
there are some down here.
We have a wonderful list of six
novels, all brought to you by
students from this class.
I'll tell you,
my dream is that one day
someone will pitch their own
novel.
That's my dream,
and yeah, this could happen.
Yes.
Okay. Are you ready?
Ballot? Here you go.
So, without further ado,
is everybody ready?
Now, each of these students has
been given five minutes only to
make their presentation,
and at the end of it you will
rank your top three choices,
1 for your first choice,
2 for your second choice, 3.
The TFs will take your ballots.
They will leave the room.
I will begin to lecture on
Housekeeping, and
when they've added it all up,
which should go pretty fast
because there are nine of them
and they're very good at adding.
You have to know that to get in
to the Ph.D.
programs here.
There is a little arithmetic
test.
They will add it all up,
and then I will announce at the
end of the class which book it
will be.
So, without further ado,
Emma Barash will come and talk
to us.
Emma: Well,
thank you, Professor
Hungerford.
I'm Emma Barash,
and I am pitching Giovanni's
Room by James Baldwin.
So, what is Baldwin like?
Well, Baldwin is one of the
great twentieth-century American
authors, and he has some really
unique insights into human
interaction and a shrewd
sensitivity into the internal
lives of his characters.
His background kind of shines
through his prose.
He is the son of a preacher,
so his words have this really
strong, sort of,
grandness to them,
and there's a really,
really unique resonance to
everything he writes.
Anyway, so Baldwin,
in my opinion,
isn't read as often as he
should in academic settings,
so I chose this book because I
wanted to use this opportunity
to read Baldwin at Yale.
And a nifty little fact about
Giovanni's Room:
It's about 150 pages.
Yeah.
And, it's eminently readable,
so that's a big plus at the end
of the semester.
But also,
I didn't just choose
Giovanni's Room because
it's short.
I chose it because it fits
seamlessly with our syllabus.
So, what's Giovanni's Room
about?
Well, Giovanni's Room is
the story of David,
a twenty-something man who
flees America to Paris in hopes
of finding himself.
While in Paris David finds a
fiancé,
Hella, and, in her absence,
another lover,
Giovanni, a man.
So, the novel spirals around
David's reverie on one
particular evening,
the evening of Giovanni's
execution.
I don't want to ruin any more
of the book, so I'll let you
wonder what offense Giovanni has
committed.
Now, Giovanni's Room
fits with the notion of the
Identity Plot which Professor
Hungerford was discussing a lot
last week,
but here the identity problem
is founded in sexuality,
a fascinating issue which the
literature we've studied so far
has yet to explore.
So, Giovanni's Room
complicates the Identity
Plot further,
but Giovanni's Room also
explores national identity.
It is an American novel of
expatriotism,
an American in Paris.
So without further ado I want
to read a passage in which David
realizes his alienation from
America and from American-ness.
So, here he is walking into the
American post office in Paris to
pick up his mail:
Yet walking into the
American Express office one
harshly gray midsummer
afternoon,
I was forced to admit that this
active, so disquietingly
cheerful horde struck the eye at
once as a unit.
At home I could have
distinguished patterns,
habits, accents of speech with
no effort whatever.
Now, everybody sounded,
unless I listened hard,
as though they had just arrived
from Nebraska.
At home I could have seen the
clothes they were wearing,
but here I only saw bags,
cameras, belts and hats--all
clearly from the same department
store.
At home I would have had some
sense of the individual
womanhood of the women I faced.
Here, the most ferociously
accomplished seemed to be
involved in some ice-cold or
sun-dried travesty of sex,
and even grandmothers seemed to
have had no traffic with the
flesh.
And what distinguished the men
was that they seemed incapable
of age.
They smelled of soap,
which seemed,
indeed, to be their
preservative against the dangers
and exigencies of any more
intimate odor.
The boy he had been shone
somehow unsoiled,
untouched, unchanged through
the eyes of the man of sixty,
booking passage with his
smiling wife to Rome.
His wife might have been his
mother forcing more oatmeal down
his throat, and Rome might have
been the movie she had promised
to allow him to see.
Yet, I also suspected that what
I was seeing was but a part of
the truth, and perhaps not even
the most important part.
Beneath these faces,
these clothes,
accents, rudenesses was power
and sorrow,
both unadmitted,
unrealized, the power of
inventors, the sorrow of the
disconnected.
Okay. All right.
Here you see that miserable
sense of separation,
that confusion,
that hopelessness that Baldwin
crafts,
that loss of identity,
and perhaps you can begin to
see the beauty and the might of
his language which molds such a
powerful story of love,
of loss, and--most
importantly--of self.
Okay. Thank you.
Professor Amy
Hungerford: All right.
Kelsey, where are you?
There you are.
Kelsey: Hello.
I'm Kelsey, and the book that
I'm pitching is One Flew Over
the Cuckoo's Nest by Ken
Kesey.
It is about a certain insane
asylum, and the narrator is a
six-foot-seven schizophrenic
deaf mute Indian chief named
Chief Bromden,
whose life is turned upside
down by a brutal and hedonistic
man named Randall McMurphy.
And Ken Kesey,
who I need to talk about a
little bit, was sort of a rock
star.
He was to the hippie generation
what Jack Kerouac was to the
Beat generation.
He was an era's most outspoken
proponent of LSD.
He and his Merry Pranksters
went on the road in their Magic
Bus touting it across the
nation.
One road trip that he took in
1964 with Neal Cassady,
the same Neal Cassady who Dean
Moriarty was crafted after,
was written down in a book by
Tom Wolfe called The Electric
Kool-Aid Acid Trip
so he has that,
sort of, in common with Jack
Kerouac.
And I'd like to play a little
clip that I have from a BBC
interview with Kesey about LSD's
effects on his writing.
Oh, just some background
information: While he was
writing One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest, he was
working in a mental institution.
[Announcer:]
Kesey's experiences at the
hospital inspire him to write a
novel, One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest.
He claims the drugs
enhanced his creativity.
[Kesey:]
I would have not been able to
write that well without LSD.
I could see a reality with a
new light shining on it,
and it goes right through your
eyes to your fingertips.
Taking acid was a shortcut to
enlightenment that we were given
in this century,
for those of us who would like
to go on to better realities and
understand and respect and say,
"Okay.
The door has been opened.
This is the key that opened
it."
Kelsey: Okay.
So, the door that Kesey opens
in One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest reveals the inner
workings of an insane asylum.
This, of course,
draws attention to the one most
obvious, and also most
complicating theme of the book,
that of madness.
We've touched on the theme of
madness before with Lolita
and with Franny and
Zooey,
but I don't think we
have addressed it as explicitly
as we would with this book.
The book is set in an insane
asylum.
There is no way to avoid
insanity.
At first glance that might seem
like a very straightforward
assertion.
However, the very sense of
omnipresent madness in the book
is one that, I think,
ropes this book very neatly
into the argument of Professor
Hungerford's syllabus.
I think it's an intensification
of most of the themes we've
studied so far,
for example the Identity Plot.
I think it's a very unique
manifestation of the Identity
Plot, because the people in the
insane asylum are perhaps one of
the most isolated groups that
you could possibly be a part of.
They're isolated by their own
neuroses, the tyranny of the
nurses and a barricade of
concrete, plexiglass and barbed
wire.
I think if you imagine any
attempt to find yourself within
the confines of a sanitorium,
you can sort of see how
interesting a story would be
crafted on that.
Another theme that we have
talked about is the relationship
between language and experience.
We talked about that with John
Barth, and I think that's a
really important question to
focus on,
when you're reading a book like
this, because you have to think
to yourself as you're reading:
how does an author accurately
capture the experience of
insanity,
and, more importantly,
how can we as readers trust a
narrator that's self-diagnosed
as insane?
And, in that same vein:
what is truth,
and how does one portray truth?
I'd like to read a passage from
the book.
This is at the very beginning,
when we're first introduced to
the Chief, and he decides that
he is going to begin telling
about all this:
…about the
hospital, and her,
and the guys,
and about McMurphy.
I've been silent so long,
now it's going to roar out of
me like flood waters,
and you think the guy telling
this is ranting and raving.
My God, you think this is too
horrible to have really
happened.
This is too awful to be the
truth, but, please,
it's so hard for me to have a
clear mind thinking on it,
but it's the truth even if it
didn't happen.
So, I think you can see the
confusion that can arise from
having an insane narrator.
One of the most enticing
aspects of this book is that it
is funny.
There are extremely hilarious
aspects of this book.
I don't know if any of you have
seen the movie,
or at least that famous clip of
Jack Nicholson laughing like a
maniac.
The movie, in general,
doesn't do the book justice at
all, whatsoever,
of course.
But I think that one moment is
quintessentially Ken Kesey,
and he uses humor as his most
powerful tool in conveying his
deep and serious messages in
this book.
One thing that I want to
point out is,
there is this really
fascinating thing that happens
over the course of this book,
and it's this.
There is an X that frames the
plot.
And that X: one arm is the
Chief's ascension from insanity,
and the other arm is McMurphy's
descension into insanity.
And I think,
if we choose this book,
one of the most challenging
aspects of our analysis of it
will be to find where the two
slopes of those intersect.
Just to wrap up,
I think that this book is
absolutely phenomenal,
and it's completely engrossing.
My own introduction to it was
completely random.
It was one of the books that my
roommate happened to throw into
her suitcase before she came to
Yale, and I read it at the
beginning of the year.
I took it with me to my
grandparents' over a weekend,
and I didn't sleep the entire
weekend 'cause I was reading it.
And I think,
if you choose this book,
each and every one of you will
be equally as enthralled.
So, I hope you pick it.
Professor Amy
Hungerford:
Miranda.Miranda:
Hi.
I'm pitching Joan Didion's
Play It As It Lays.
Joan Didion is,
in my mind, one of the greatest
intellectuals of the second half
of the twentieth century.
She is perhaps best known for
her journalism,
particularly her collection of
essays,
Slouching Towards Bethlehem,
which I believe came out in
1968, in which she coolly
confronts and sensibly analyzes
the confusing cultural climate
of the late 1960s.
What I think is most remarkable
about her reporting is the lack
of naiveté
with which this literally tiny
woman-- I don't know if you any
of you seen a picture of her.
She's just remarkably small.
So, she is clear-eyed,
but not unsympathetic,
innocent but detached,
and above all candid in her
assessment of her country and
her time.
The voice that she develops in
Slouching Towards Bethlehem
serves her very well in
Play It As It Lays.
She's able here,
too, to draw the same sort of
precise portraits that she
relied upon in her nonfiction,
that results in a novel that is
positively, undeniably
seductive.
The plot revolves around a
sort of marginal actress,
Maria Wyeth,
who is divorced from her
director husband and who drifts
aimlessly through the Hollywood
party scene of the late 1960s
waiting for something to touch
her,
impact her emotionally and
morally.
She's both damaged and,
as a result,
utterly unreachable.
Tragedies--and there are many,
major and minor,
that sort of blithely by--slip
off her or appear to.
It is a novel very much about a
woman who accepts everything,
feels nothing,
and finally resigns herself to
the inevitable.
The inevitable is,
in many cases,
trivial fates dealt out at
cocktail parties.
It is told in several voices,
Maria's and three of her
closest friends,
and each character is haunted
by an ineffable loss of meaning
and consequences that they
either ignore or are ignorant
of,
willfully or otherwise.
In many ways these characters'
lives are coming or drifting
apart, and their lack of
awareness of this fact becomes,
through Didion's prose,
our own, so that the shock of
the final scenes is both
powerful and hopelessly hollow.
And I don't mean that in the
negative sense.
I mean that we feel that
consequences perhaps are
unimportant, that there is
something larger at work.
So, Play It As It
Lays, I think,
fits very nicely into the
syllabus because it provides a
beautiful contrast to The
Crying of Lot 49 in that it
depicts the disintegration of
southern California,
and specifically L.A.,
in a much less manic,
but no less troubling way.
Didion's language,
in its flat,
plain tone, mimics the flat,
plain Los Angeles of her
narrative,
as Pynchon's convoluted,
elusive language does his
perplexing and intricate
portrait of the city.
Also, as with
Housekeeping,
the loss of self is imagined as
a dispersal,
though Didion's dispersal is a
cold, defensive and ultimately
empty one.
Slouching Towards
Bethlehem begins with a
quote from Yeats that includes
the phrase "The center will not
hold."
This has become very emblematic
of that era.
Maria, who in the first few
pages declares that nothing
applies to her,
is perhaps one of the most
poignant examples of the
personal consequences of the
loosening,
the loss of cultural
restrictions in the 1960s,
a time when,
in fact, none of the old rules
applied to her or anyone else.
Didion proposes that the
consequences of this freedom
might be more than any single
individual can cope with,
that in fact if nothing
applies, the individual center,
no lesson societies cannot
hold.
It is an account of the '60s
that appears perhaps elsewhere,
but was, I think,
defined by Didion in this
novel, and I want to read a very
brief passage from the
beginning.
Here we go.
I am what I am.
To look for reasons is beside
the point.
But because the pursuit of
reasons is their business
here--[she is,
I believe,
at this point
institutionalized]
they ask me questions:
"Maria, yes or no:
I see a clock in this inkblot.
Maria, yes or no?"
A large number of people are
guilty of bad sexual conduct.
I believe my sins are
unpardonable.
I have been disappointed in
love.
How could I answer?
How could it apply?
"Nothing applies," I print with
a magnetized IBM pencil.
"What does apply?"
they ask later,
as if the word "nothing" were
ambiguous, open to
interpretation,
a questionable fragment of an
Icelandic rune.
"There are only certain facts,"
I say, trying again to be an
agreeable player of the game,
"certain facts,
certain things that happened."
They will misread the facts,
invent connections,
will extrapolate reasons where
none exist, but,
I told you, that is their
business here.
And I think it would be
wonderful to end the semester
with a strong female voice that
is darkly amusing,
courageous and,
especially, cold.
And I don't mean cold in the
negative sense;
just that she approaches things
in a sort of detached way that
allows you to observe these
characters,
but not attach yourselves to
them in a way that promotes a
sort of self-identification that
makes it difficult for you to
judge their actions.
It's also fairly short,
just over 200 pages:
a fast, captivating read.
This is a sort of stupid
analogy, but I imagine it's sort
of like getting on a highway in
L.A.
(not during rush hour) but
heading to where you're going,
maybe east towards the hills,
and you get to your exit,
sort of, before you realize it.
So that's my pitch.
Thank you.Will: Hi.
My name is Will.
I'm pitching Jesus' Son
by Denis Johnson.
I'm actually going to start
without introducing it at all.
I'm just going to play a clip
from the movie that was made of
the book.
I'm not even going to talk
about it.
Will: That was a clip
from the movie version of
Jesus' Son, and
this is the book.
It's by Denis Johnson,
who has been in the news a lot
lately because he wrote Tree
of Smoke, which won
the National Book Award in 2007.
And this book is,
kind of, the book that
established him as a serious,
great author,
and I think it's wonderful.
It's a collection of stories,
and they're all kind of about
the same character,
one of the characters you saw
in there, and kind of the same
group of characters runs through
all the different stories.
And so, it's kind of novelistic
in that way, kind of like
Lost in the Funhouse,
the book we read.
I guess, as you might or might
not have been able to tell from
the clip, the book kind of deals
with drug addiction,
and the main character is
addicted to heroin.
But I really think the book
kind of transcends the drug
genre.
I'm not a huge fan of drug
books, myself,
but I think this book is really
beautiful and powerful and
devastating and really
hilarious,
really funny at times.
What else?
It's short (like everyone else
has been saying),
but this book really is short.
It's only 160 pages,
and there really aren't very
many words on each page,
'cause it's quite small,
as you can see.
And really, I find this book--
I don't know how much I want to
describe it, but it takes place
mostly in Iowa and kind of just
travels around,
kind of daily things.
In one of the stories the main
character and his friend decide
to rip scrap metal from a house
and sell it to make a little
money so they can get drunk that
night,
and just different kind of
adventures that they go on.
And then the book kind of ends
as he makes this kind of
pilgrimage to Arizona.
It's really beautiful.
I guess I'll just read you a
quick passage,
if that's all right.
We bumped softly down a
hill toward an open field that
seemed to be a military
graveyard filled with rows and
rows of austere identical
markers over soldiers' graves.
I'd never before come across
this cemetery.
On the farther side of the
field, just beyond the curtains
of snow, the sky was torn away
and the angels were descending
out of a brilliant blue summer,
their huge faces streaked with
light and full of pity.
The sight of them cut through
my heart and down the knuckles
of my spine, and if there had
been anything in my bowels I
would have messed my pants from
fear.
Georgie opened his arms and
cried out, "It's the drive-in,
man, the drive-in!"
I wasn't sure what these words
meant.
"They're showing movies in a
fucking blizzard," Georgie
screamed.
"I see.
I thought it was something
else," I said.
We walked carefully down there
and climbed through the busted
fence and stood in the very
back.
The speakers which I had
mistaken for grave markers
muttered in unison.
Then there was tinkly music of
which I could very nearly make
out the tune.
Famous movie stars rode
bicycles beside a river,
laughing out of their gigantic,
lovely mouths.
If anybody had ever come to see
the show, they'd have left when
the weather started.
Not one car remained,
not even a broken-down one from
last week, or one left here
because it was out of gas.
In a couple of minutes,
in the middle of a whirling
square dance,
the screen turned black,
the cinematic summer ended,
the snow went dark,
there was nothing but my
breath.
So, I guess that gives you
enough of an idea of it.
I think it's great and I think
you should vote for it.
It's a quick read.
It's really riveting and
enthralling and I find it really
an incredible book.
So, Jesus' Son.
Eli: Hi. I'm Eli.
The book I wanted to pitch was
Everything is Illuminated
by Jonathan Safran Foer.
And the main reason I wanted to
pitch it, of course,
was: Professor Hungerford said
that she's waiting for one of us
to pitch their own book,
and--contrary to conventional
wisdom--this is actually my own
book, just so you know.
But, setting aside authorship
issues--the thing is,
you just had to introduce the
seed of doubt,
and then the rumors percolate,
so this is good--I love books
that have outrageous characters.
Actually, hearing some of these
pitches, I was like,
"oh, maybe I should vote for
some of the other books."
But I won't tell you that.
But, this book does have
outrageous characters,
which is really cool.
And also, I just thought,
the pitch, I would just kind of
describe some of the characters,
and you'd be like,
"those characters are indeed
outrageous," or go,
"I will vote for this book."
So, the book kind of takes
place in two different worlds.
One is the world of
Trachimbrod, which is a small
shtetl in the eighteenth
century, and also Jonathan
Safran Foer's ancestral home.
And the other world is kind of
modern day Ukraine and it
features Jonathan Safran Foer on
a quest.
As, I don't know if you Jews
out there, I'm sure,
at some point,
have done this,
as I have, been drawn to
Slovakia or Ukraine to find the
ancestral home,
and that's what Jonathan Safran
Foer is doing in this book.
So, in the, kind of,
modern-day world,
there are a number of really
cool characters.
The main one is the hero,
Jonathan Safran Foer,
who is also referred to as the
"spoiled Jew" and the "ingenious
Jew."
The other character is his
humble translator,
Alexander Perchov,
who learned English exclusively
through the use of a thesaurus
(which produces some outrageous
results) and who works for the
family business,
Heritage Touring.
His description of it is:
It's for Jewish people
like the hero who have cravings
to leave the ennobled country
America and visit humble towns
in Poland and Ukraine.
I will be truthful again and
mention that before this voyage
I had the opinion that Jewish
people were having shit between
their brains.
That is because all I knew of
Jewish people was that they paid
father very much currency in
order to make vacations from
America to Ukraine.
Food for thought.
And then there's also Alex's
dog, Sammy Davis Junior,
Jr., which is Heritage
Touring's "officious seeing-eye
bitch."
So, that's one world.
And in the other world,
the world of the shtetl,
we have a Well-Regarded Rabbi
who speaks exclusively in
capitals.
We have Brod,
a brilliant girl who emerges
magically from a river and is
adopted by the disgraced usurer,
Yankel D.
We have two synagogues,
the Congregation of the
Slouchers and the Congregation
of the Upright.
We have villagers,
including the deceased
philosopher, Pinchas T,
who in his only notable paper,
"To the Dust:
From Man You Came and to Man
You Shall Return," argues that
it would be possible,
in theory, for life and art to
be reversed.
We have the good gefilte-fish
monger, Bitzl Bitzl R.
We have the mad squire and
village rapist,
Sofiowka N.
We have Harry V,
the shtetl's master logician
and resident pervert,
who had been working for many
years on his magnum opus,
"The Host of Hoists," which,
he promised,
contained the tightest of tight
logical proofs that God
indiscriminately loves the
indiscriminate lover.
So, I don't know how many of us
that will pardon,
in here…
So, besides these
outrageous characters,
I do think this book fits well
with the themes of the course.
It deals with identity,
language and experience,
and problems of narration and
remembrance.
As the New York Times Book
Review (I guess you could
say) lauded the book,
"Not since A Clockwork
Orange has the English
language been simultaneously
mauled and energized with such
brilliance and such brio."
So, going with that,
I thought I'd read,
as people have been inclined to
do, a passage from the book.
I'm going to take a little risk
here.
I've been reading the book with
a Russian accent in my head,
so I figured I would just go
with that here.
I figured that would have the
added benefit of:
If you don't vote for this
book,
then I'll just be the kid who
made a fool of himself and read
with a Russian accent in front
of everybody.
So, I know you don't want to do
that to me.
Yeah. Okay, I think. All right.
So here we go.
This is Alex kind of
introducing himself at the
beginning of the book:
"I dig Negroes,
particularly Michael Jackson.
I dig to disseminate very much
currency at famous nightclubs in
Odessa.
Lamborghini Countaches are
excellent so are cappuccinos.
Many girls want to be carnal
with me in many good
arrangements,
notwithstanding the Inebriated
Kangaroo,
the Gorky Tickle and the
Unyielding Zookeeper.
If you want to know why so many
girls want to be with me,
it is because I am very premium
person to be with.
I am homely and also severely
funny and these are winning
things.
But nonetheless I know many
people who dig rapid cars and
famous discotheques.
There are so many here who
perform the Sputnik Bosom
Dalliance--which is always
terminated with a slimy
underface--that I cannot tally
them on all of my hands.
There are even many people
named Alex.
(Three in my house alone!) That
is why I was so effervescent to
go to Lutsk and translate for
Jonathan Safran Foer.
It would be unordinary.
So that's said,
and a fool proudly made.
That's it.
Thank you.
Roger:
Well, it's really
unfortunate to have to go after
that, but hi.
My name's Roger.
I'm presenting for Amina's
section, and we're doing Dave
Eggers' What is the What
(and you can't see the
"What" because it's 20% off;
plug, plug).
And, I guess,
rather than try to sum up the
book myself, I'll use not the
author's but the person about
whom the book is written's own
words: "What is the What
is the soulful account of my
life,
from the time I was separated
from my family in Marial Bai
---- to the thirteen years I
spent in Ethiopian and Kenyan
refugee camps,
to my encounter with vibrant
Western cultures beginning in
Atlanta, to the generosity and
challenges that I encountered
elsewhere.
So, just to add a little
bit to that, What is the What
is a story of a Sudanese
refugee in the United States.
And in the course of telling
it, he reads an account from his
life back in Africa,
to stories here in the United
States, and everything in
between.
As for reasons why you should
want to vote for it or read it,
I think the first thing which
many of us in the section
realize about the book is just
that it's really engaging.
It's written in a way that's,
I would say,
kind of refreshing compared to
some of the other more--how to
put it?--complex authors that
we've read,
in that it's just really
accessible and really just an
easy read that's deeply human.
You feel like you're having a
conversation with the guy,
and (even though the guy is
actually having a conversation
with Dave Eggers,
so maybe that's why you get
that impression,
but at any rate) it's also a
book which manages to address
really,
really serious current issues
such as civil war,
genocide, alienation in
American society,
but do so in a way that's
simultaneously really poignant
and inspiring,
but also,
actually, funny.
It's not a book that you're
going to read and be depressed
by, even though you will come
from it having really felt that
you're dealing with really
significant material,
which I thought is really cool,
and we thought was really cool.
It's also--just going on to
the whole contemporary thing--
it's written by one of the best
contemporary authors out there.
He was nominated for a Pulitzer;
he was a Pulitzer Prize
finalist, I think,
last year, 2007.
(I'm not sure,
and if I got that wrong and
someone here is a big Eggers
fan, I'm terribly sorry.) But
yeah;
he's great.
And, in a course where we're
doing from 1945 to the present,
I think it's good to have a
really strong,
really contemporary author
represented.
So, that's another cool thing.
Another thing which I think
would be really cool about
reading this book is that - it's
not your standard academic book
at all.
You're not going to find this
book on any syllabus,
but it still really merits
being read in that sort of a
context because of the depth of
the material that's being
covered,
because of the way it's written.
Really, there are some
beautiful descriptions with
beautiful language.
And, well, for any other reason
that you'd want to read a book
in a class, it can serve that
function,
and yet you'd probably more
like to hear about it in a
coffee shop or in a restaurant.
So, I think that's a pretty
cool opportunity which this
would give us.
As far as tying in to the
course matters,
this book is a great,
great study,
and, I would think,
an unprecedented study,
as far as the Identity Plot
goes,
for our class,
because as a black African the
protagonist is identified not by
his ethnicity in the United
States,
but by his race.
And, as is shown in a really
very interesting,
I guess, scene,
at the very beginning of the
book,
where he's being robbed by a
black man who says to him,
"Oh, well, we're brothers
because you're African" and at
the same time derides,
only refers to him as African
and actually mislabels him as
Nigerian when he's Sudanese.
So, it really offers some
really interesting perspective
into issues of race,
issues of ethnicity,
and just a totally new look at
American society from,
yeah,
a perspective that we're not
really used to.
I guess, yeah,
that basically covers that.
As far as some other,
maybe a little bit sillier
things, this is a great date
book for those of you who either
are dating or are looking to be
dating.
It's a book that people are
reading all of the time,
and, even if they aren't
reading,
then you can really wow them
with just your knowledge of
contemporary literature,
and to say nothing of your
concern for the people who are
struggling in America and
abroad.
So, really, that's a big plug.
And it's also won a bunch of
awards.
It was a finalist for the
National Book Critics Circle
Award for Fiction,
which I think is good,
and the guy from Barnes &
Noble would not let me leave
the counter because he liked it
so much, and he is a good judge.
So, those are some really
good plugs but as far as a
weakness, you might notice it's
a little bit bigger than some of
the other books that we've read,
but I promise you that that's
okay.
You fly through the pages,
and just to give you a sense of
why you do that,
I'll read to you a section from
the book.
It's actually the last
paragraph of the book,
but it's not like one of those
spoilers, like "And then your
mother died."
No.
It actually,
really, I think,
is very fitting to read,
now, because it's kind of his
plug for why you should read his
book,
or at least it's a description
of why he tells this story.
So here we go.
Whatever I do,
however I find a way to live,
I will tell these stories.
I have spoken to every person I
have encountered these last
difficult days,
and every person who has
entered this club during these
awful morning hours,
because to do anything else
would be something less than
human.
I speak to these people,
and I speak to you,
because I cannot help it.
It gives me strength,
almost unbelievable strength,
to know that you are there.
I covet your eyes,
your ears, the collapsible
space between us.
How blessed are we to have each
other.
I am alive, and you are alive,
so we must fill the air with
our words.
I will fill today,
tomorrow, every day until I am
taken back to God.
I will tell these stories to
people who will listen and to
people who don't want to listen,
to people who seek me out and
to those who run.
All the while I will know that
you are there.
How can I pretend that you do
not exist?
It would be almost as
impossible as you pretending
that I do not exist.
Thanks.
Professor Amy
Hungerford: Okay.
Vote.
If this were really a high-tech
classroom, we'd have a little
console for you,
and you'd be voting online,
but we don't.
Okay. Okay.
Anyone need a ballot?
Okay. Rank them 1,2, 3.
TAs get to vote, too.
Yes, you do.
And when you're finished,
pass them to the aisles.
Can I borrow your pencil?
I am voting too.
Okay. Everybody voted?
Okay, TFs.
Everybody done?
Pass them over.
Okay.
We will see them in a moment.
Well, let me say it's a tough
act to follow you guys so
congratulations to all the
people who pitched books,
although I have to say I am a
little hurt at the implied
criticism.
Long?
Hard?
Boring?
I don't recognize my own
syllabus.
Maybe the long,
but not the hard and the
boring.
So, we will see what that next
book will be.
Now, I have exactly five
minutes, so what I think I want
to do is just say something very
quick about loss in this book.
I put this quote up on the
board: "Need can blossom into
all the compensation it
requires."
That little blurb,
I think, encapsulates this
novel's meditation on loss.
I asked you last time to think
about where Ruth's voice comes
from, what situation we can
imagine,
and there are a bunch of
different theories that critics
have put forward about where
Ruth is and from where we hear
her voice coming.
One is that she's dead and
she's speaking to us from the
afterlife, that she really,
somehow, did die in the lake
that day, that she fell off the
bridge, or somehow the bridge is
a metaphor for her passage into
death.
Or that this is an adult Ruth,
living who knows where,
or just as a transient,
who has written this account,
or who speaks to us,
somehow.
I think that quotation from
Marilynne Robinson that I gave
you at the end of last lecture,
about how she aims to speak in
the voice of the consciousness
of the person--not necessarily
the words that they would use if
they were to write their own
account--suggests that what she
is getting at doesn't require
that kind of historical
explanation to account for it,
that she doesn't want us to
have to think of Ruth speaking
from a particular place,
which is also a way to say that
Ruth is gone;
somehow Ruth is absent from us.
And this relates to my point
last time about how identity is
imagined as voice.
Ruth, the historical Ruth,
the character Ruth,
a Ruth that we could situate in
any concrete position in the
world,
has vanished from the frame of
this novel.
What we're left with is her
voice.
The logic here is that
vanishing makes the voice
totally present;
that full human presence is in
the voice, somehow inherent.
That's why there are all of
these meditations on what would
happen if various people either
did disappear or didn't
disappear.
So, when Ruth meditates on what
it would be like for her to
leave Sylvie,
she says, "I did not want to
grow gigantic and multiple to
Sylvie."
Her sense is that,
by leaving Sylvie,
her absence would become
enormous, and she herself,
in a kind of negative presence,
would become larger than she
is, and this is how Ruth feels
about her own mother's
disappearance,
that when her mother
disappeared, what she got in
return was the compensation of
memory: sharp,
specific, evocative,
mysterious, ever-present
memory.
And the visual metaphor for
this kind of memory is,
of course, the lake.
The lake is imagined to contain
whole and undecayed all the
objects of the past that have
been lost in it.
So memory is imagined in the
same terms, so that you could
always bring them up to the
surface and there they would be,
whole.
So, the resurrection
imagined, if you run the film
backward of the train slipping
in to the lake--I read that
passage last time--the kind of
resurrection imagined,
is the way memory works.
But more specifically it's the
way the language of memory
works.
And I want to read my own
favorite passage.
This is at the very end of the
novel, and I want you to think,
as I read it,
about the difference between
this passage and the one I read
from Bluest Eye about
Pecola,
that passage of negativity
about her being a kind of blank
or a negative,
against which all other virtues
could be present in the world.
So, think about that as I read
this, the bottom of 217:
Since we are dead,
the house would be hers now
[hers, Lucille].
Perhaps she is in the kitchen
snuggling pretty daughters in
her lap.
And perhaps now and then they
look at the black window to find
out what their mother seems to
see there,
and they see their own faces
and a face so like their
mother's, so rapt and full of
tender watching,
that only Lucille could think
the face was mine.
If Lucille is there,
Sylvie and I have stood outside
her window a thousand times and
we have thrown the side door
open when she was upstairs
changing beds and we have
brought in leaves and flung the
curtains and tipped the bud vase
and somehow left the house again
before she could run downstairs,
leaving behind us a strong
smell of lake water.
She would sigh and think,
"they never change."
Or imagine Lucille in Boston,
at a table in a restaurant
waiting for a friend.
She is tastefully dressed,
wearing, say,
a tweed suit with an amber
scarf at the throat,
to draw attention to the red in
her darkening hair.
Her water glass has left two
thirds of a ring on the table
and she works at completing the
circle with her thumbnail.
Sylvie and I do not flounce in
through the door,
smoothing the skirts of our
oversized coats and combing our
hair back with our fingers.
We do not sit down at the table
next to hers and empty our
pockets in a small,
damp heap in the middle of the
table and sort out the gum
wrappers and ticket stubs and
add up the coins and dollar
bills and laugh and add them
again.
My mother, likewise,
is not there,
and my grandmother in her house
slippers with her pigtail
wagging,
and my grandfather with his
hair combed flat against his
brow does not examine the menu
with studious interest.
We are nowhere in Boston.
However Lucille may look,
she will never find us there,
or any trace or sign.
We pause nowhere in Boston,
even to admire a store window
and the perimeters of our
wandering are nowhere.
No one watching this woman
smear her initials in the steam
on her water glass with her
first finger,
or slip cellophane packets of
oyster crackers into her handbag
for the seagulls could know how
her thoughts are thronged by our
absence,
or know how she does not watch,
does not listen,
does not wait,
does not hope,
and always for me and
Sylvie.
So, you see in that incredibly
lyrical evocation of absence how
the very absence calls forth
this lyric voice.
The structure is exactly the
same as the one that Morrison
uses to describe what Pecola is
to Claudia and Frieda and the
rest of their community.
It's a way in which absence
calls forth the living essence
of other people,
but here what's called forth is
a sort of living essence of
imagination,
a living essence of voice,
so that Sylvie and Ruth's
absence for Lucille becomes the
very presence that they have to
her.
There is a passage earlier in
the novel where she describes
the condition of the body that
matches up with this
understanding of absence.
She's outside in the
orchard--this is on
203--imagining the story of a
young girl in a lighted house
that she sees.
Let's see.
It would be that kind of story,
a very melancholy story.
Her hair,
which was as black as the sky,
and so long that it swept after
her,
a wind in the grass,
her fingers,
which were sky black and so
fine and slender that they were
only cold touch like drops of
rain,
her step, which was so silent
that people were surprised when
they even thought they heard it,
she would be transformed by the
growth of light into a mortal
child.
And, when she stood at the
bright window,
she would find that the world
was gone,
the orchard was gone,
her mother and grandmother and
aunts were gone.
Like Noah's wife on the tenth
or fifteenth night of rain,
she would stand in the window
and realize that the world was
really lost.
And those outside would
scarcely know her,
so sadly was she changed.
Before she had been fleshed in
air, and clothed in nakedness,
and mantled in cold,
and her very bones were only
slender things like shards of
ice.
She had haunted the orchard out
of preference,
but she could walk into the
lake without ripple or
displacement,
and sail up the air invisibly
as heat.
And now, lost to her kind,
she would almost forget them,
and she would feed coarse food
to her coarse flesh and be
almost satisfied.
And then Ruth meditates on her
transformation in that time in
the orchard.
If I had stayed there,
I might have discovered other
things.
For example,
I was hungry enough to begin to
learn that hunger has its
pleasures, and I was happily at
ease in the dark.
And, in general,
I could feel that I was
breaking the tethers of need,
one by one.
I would call this an anorexic
aesthetic.
It's an aesthetic of starving
the self into invisibility so
that the voice can become
present.
So in this scene,
when she imagines the girl
inside the house eating,
all that's outside the house is
lost.
All she can see when she looks
out her window is her own
reflection.
But outside the house,
she is starved in to a kind of
ethereal, full presence.
So the logic of absence--to
bring it back around to this
question of identity and the
identity of the voice--the logic
of absence starves away the
person so that this fullness can
appear.
And I think this is the dark
side of a novel that so many
people initially read as a
feminist novel,
a novel celebrating the
strength and the independence of
women.
It turns to an aesthetic that
has a kind of purchase in our
culture;
that sense of anorexia blends
into the spiritual fullness of
imagining memory as this
beautiful, lyrical presence.
I think this is the complexity
of this novel;
this is the tension.
It's also, in many ways,
its beauty.
So, now I believe we have
an answer.
Jonathan Safran Foer.
That will be our novel.
Eli, congratulations.
Thank you very much.
Have a wonderful break.